Some films tell intricate stories filled with
twists — like the search for truth in
All the President’s Men
the dark tangents of Mulholland Drive,
, or the trippy lunacy of Being John Malkovich.
Other times, the story is very simple, while
the telling is remarkably complex.
Steven Soderbergh’s 1999 film The Limey
is one of those movies.
By using unusual or even experimental techniques,
filmmakers can draw out the themes of a film
and challenge viewers to look at cinema in
a whole new way.
From its scrambled timeline to its occasionally
avant garde editing style, The Limey takes
a familiar plot and layers it with deeper
meaning.
This film shows how movies, more than any
other medium, can mirror the ways our minds
work and how memories unfold.
I'm Michael Aranda, this is Crash Course Film Criticism, and I have a cold.
[intro music plays]
In 1998, Steven Soderbergh had just finished
directing Out of Sight, the sexy crime thriller
starring George Clooney and Jennifer Lopez.
And he was gearing up to make Erin Brockovich
and win a Best Director Oscar for Traffic.
But before scaling the heights of mainstream
Hollywood, he turned his attention to a little
revenge thriller written by Lem Dobbs, best
known for writing the sci-fi noir cult hit, Dark City.
The Limey follows a British thief named Wilson,
played with steely conviction by Terence Stamp.
He travels to Los Angeles fresh from prison
to investigate the death of his daughter Jenny.
The thing is, Wilson’s been incarcerated
for most of Jenny’s life.
He barely knows her.
So he starts filling in the gaps.
He gets help from Eduardo, a fellow ex-con
played by Luis Guzman.
Eduardo knew Jenny and becomes Wilson’s
reluctant sidekick.
Wilson also connects with Elaine, a former
actress and mentor of Jenny’s, played with
tragic grace by Leslie Ann Warren.
The trail ultimately points to Terry Valentine,
a former music producer who was dating Jenny
at the time of her death.
Played by Peter Fonda, Valentine is a vapid,
charming sleaze-ball.
He’s recently started laundering money for
a drug cartel to make ends meet.
Wilson spends the movie circling his target,
investigating Jenny’s death, and avoiding
a pair of hitmen hired to take him out.
There are flashes of violence, moments of
deadpan humor, and a galvanizing 1960s soundtrack.
The final gun battle at Valentine’s beach
house in Big Sur, California leaves most of
Valentine’s crew dead or dying.
Eventually, Wilson chases a wounded Valentine
to a rocky beach, and he gets the whole story.
Jenny had discovered Valentine’s illegal
activities and threatened to turn him in.
Valentine panicked and tried to stop her,
and in their struggle, she struck her head
and died.
Wilson remembers Jenny threatening to call
the cops on him when she was a young girl
— without ever following through on her
threats.
And, in that moment, he recognizes that he
played a part in her death.
He leaves Valentine bleeding on the beach
as the tide comes rolling in.
And that’s it.
It’s a pretty familiar plot, but Soderbergh
saw something else buried inside the tropes.
For him, The Limey was a deep, introspective
story about memory, regret, and forgiveness.
And Soderbergh thought that he knew how to
shoot and edit the film in ways that would
make these themes central to the experience
of watching it.
Basically, he thought he could cut the movie
so that it felt like a memory.
And when you’re critiquing a film, it can
be helpful to take a magnifying glass to the
filmmakers’ choices and techniques.
By doing that with The Limey, we can figure
out how Soderbergh adds layers of complexity
to the characters and plot of a classic revenge
story, and the ways he carefully controls
how the audience experiences it all.
Now, as we talked about in Crash Course Film
History, most films are edited using an strategy
called
continuity editing.
That means that most of the cuts are seamless,
or even invisible.
The edits are designed to make the film’s
time and space clear.
They don’t interrupt the action, and time
generally moves forward.
The Limey takes another approach.
From the first few shots, Soderbergh and editor
Sarah Flack opt for a strategy called
discontinuity editing.
Here, the edits deliberately draw attention.
The filmmakers cut back and forth within or
between scenes, without actually telling us
how they fit into the film’s timeline or
geography.
This fragments the narrative and forces the
audience into a more active role.
We have to really watch the movie and piece
it together.
It’s like solving a puzzle, which is exactly
what Wilson’s up to!
As the film progresses, we get shots of Wilson
sitting and thinking – in an airplane, unpacking
in his hotel room, turning on the shower,
then back to him on the plane, staring out
the window.
Did he get back on the plane?
Did he ever leave?
Is this a memory?
A fantasy?
A flash-forward?
The movie sets up a kind of dissonance between
sound, image, and time.
The filmmakers scramble these elements to
get at something deeper in their story.
All these cross-cut shots of Wilson give the
film a much more contemplative tone than your
average revenge thriller.
And as soon as we’re used to those, the
film deploys even more sophisticated discontinuity
editing techniques.
Soderbergh and Flack start cutting to heavily
stylized shots of a young girl on a beach.
She looks right at the camera, a circle of
reflected light flashing over her face.
This is Jenny, refracted through Wilson’s
memory.
It’s an almost ghostly image — imperfect,
sad, yet beautiful.
And these memory shots lead to other flashbacks,
often without dialogue.
They’re of a convict that looks remarkably
like a young Terence Stamp trying to maintain
a relationship with a woman and their daughter.
Turns out, it is a much younger Terence
Stamp!
Soderbergh had the idea to use a 1967 film
by Ken Loach called Poor Cow to show Wilson’s
backstory.
That film follows a single mother played by
Carol White as she struggles to make a life
for herself while dealing with a troubled
young thief played by Stamp.
Soderbergh not only uses these shots to fill
in the gaps of Wilson’s backstory, but also
to highlight The Limey’s connections to
bold British cinema of the 1960s.
In 1967, director John Boorman made Point
Blank, an aggressively non-linear revenge
thriller about a double-crossed criminal left
for dead.
Richard Lester’s Petulia from 1968 uses
discontinuity editing to reflect the scrambled,
quirky nature of the characters’ experiences.
Inspired by these and other films, Soderbergh
has played with non-linear storytelling in
everything from his debut film, sex, lies,
and videotape, to Out of Sight.
But nothing comes close to the fractured quality
of The Limey.
Two sequences especially illustrate how far
Soderbergh and Flack are willing to push the envelope.
Early in the film, Wilson visits Elaine and
takes her out to dinner.
She tells him about Jenny, painting a picture
of his daughter’s life in LA.
And he shares a heartrending story about how
he knew she’d died, before he’d been told.
It’s a straightforward conversation that
deepens our understanding of Jenny, her difficult
relationship with Wilson, and Wilson’s growing
intimacy with Elaine.
But instead of shooting the conversation in
a conventional, linear way, Soderbergh decided
to film it in three different locations: Elaine’s
apartment, the restaurant, and along a moonlit pier.
Then, when he and his editor cut the sequence
together, they kept the dialogue linear.
But visually, the film cuts between the three
locations on almost every line, scrambling
our sense of time and space.
Elaine: That's where Eddie wrote you? In prison?
Wilson: Oh no. No, no, I knew.
Wilson: I knew before hand. Uhhhh...
Wilson: What time was it supposed to have happened?
Wilson: Eddie said... two in the morning.
Wilson: Well, that's like 8 hours difference between here and London.
Wilson: That would have made it like about ten o'clock my time.
Wilson: I was just going out in the yard.
The effect is disorienting, and visually confusing.
But the emotions – the yearning, pain, and
regret – are the connective tissue throughout
the sequence and play very clearly.
To make the scene even more complex, it’s
here that Soderbergh cuts in most of the Poor
Cow footage, as Wilson thinks back to his
early days with Jenny’s mom.
It’s a risky technique, one that threatens
to confuse the audience.
But used in such an intentional way, it’s
tremendously effective.
An equally creative and effective sequence
plays out at Valentine’s house, high in
the Hollywood Hills.
Wilson and Eduardo crash a cocktail party,
because Wilson wants to see Valentine in the
flesh.
After skulking around the house and stealing
a photograph of Jenny, Wilson finds himself
out on the deck, staring back inside at an
oblivious Valentine.
Wilson’s staring is intercut with stylized,
slow motion shots of him walking in the house,
pulling his pistol, and shooting Valentine
in the chest.
Over these shots we just hear the sound
of crashing waves, a motif that recurs throughout
the film.
These choices make it clear that this is Wilson’s
fantasy, rather than something that’s
actually happening.
The film then cuts back to Wilson on the deck,
and he starts walking into the house.
And again, we cut to shots of Wilson pulling
his pistol, aiming, and firing.
This time, we hear more party noise and the
shots play at regular speed.
It feels like we’re getting closer to reality
— but not quite.
And then we cut back to Wilson entering
the house a third time.
This time, Soderbergh doesn’t stylize the
shots, and the sounds of the party play at
full volume.
So this feels very real.
Wilson pulls his gun, Valentine sees him and
freezes, and Wilson shoots Valentine in the
head.
A woman screams and we cut to…
Valentine, unhurt, as Eduardo stops Wilson
from drawing his pistol.
By gradually stripping away the slow motion
and subjective sound design, Soderbergh fools
us into believing that the third time we were
actually seeing Wilson’s revenge.
But it was really another example of how filmmaking
techniques put us in Wilson’s head, giving
us access to his imagined experience.
So how does this all work?
What makes the movie hold together, instead
of fracturing into a confusing mess?
One idea holds that our minds work by moving
back and forth in time, and in and out of fantasy.
You hear a song on the radio, which reminds
you of a high school dance, which makes you
think of that outfit you thought was so cool,
which reminds you that you need to go shopping
this weekend for a new coat, which makes you
imagine that you might bump into a local celebrity…
and so on.
Most films iron out these chains of association,
creating clear and linear stories.
Not The Limey.
Here Soderbergh uses the cinematography, editing,
and sound design to immerse us in a character’s
mind.
His goal is subjectivity, not objectivity.
And it comes full circle in the last scene.
We see Wilson back on the airplane, in the
same shots that opened the movie.
But this time we learn that he’s on his
flight back to the UK.
Suddenly, all the shots of Wilson on that
plane scattered throughout the movie take
on a new meaning.
They frame the whole film as a string of memories.
He’s sitting on the plane, thinking back
over the people he’s met and the things
he’s done.
His memory is naturally jumping back and forth,
mixing events, capturing fleeting moments,
and not always making narrative sense.
And the intended meaning of the film becomes
clear:
it’s a story about Wilson’s meditation
on regret, redemption, and the inability to
escape the past.
With The Limey, Soderbergh has taken a conventional
revenge plot and used the tools of cinema
to elevate it to something richer and more
profound.
It’s a unique puzzle of a film that gets
its power less from the story itself, and
more because of how that story is told.
Next time, we’ll find new ways to get at
a character’s subjective experience as we
look at Juliette Binoche’s performance in
Kieślowski's classic film Blue.
Crash Course Film Criticism is produced in association with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check out a playlist of their latest shows, like
PBS Infinite Series, PBS Space Time, and It's Okay to be Smart.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these [nice people] and our
amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.